drew barrymore was brought to tears
loved your bear more everybody i love
was on this show today i know uh brought
to tears as she helped one couple with
the proposal of a lifetime on the drew
barrymore show today take a look bye
i'm gonna hand this one over to you
today
take it away thank you
i wrote a little something because i uh
i write a lot i write a lot of poetry
but i knew today i needed a little help
destiny oh god
our story is one of growth communication
unwavering support and love
we might not have started because of
scream
but our
journey and our love has flourished
through all the adventures and the
amazing people that we've met along the
way
we are here because of all of those
people
and you
um and and just everybody that lifted us
up it is an honor to have this
opportunity and an even bigger one to
ask you this
with the ring that belonged to your
favorite person your grandma
i am so lucky
and we are so lucky
so destiny justine
oh god
[Music]
will you marry me
of course yeah
so happy for you